so this is a joint work so I am going to
talk about two recent results so this is
not like a survey or an overview or
something i'm going to talk about two
specific results and along the way try
to give you some background so this is
joint work with two students been
injured say she didn't in gaurav agarwal
he is a PhD student is a master student
and the recent results have to do first
the first result has to do with
regenerating codes and the second one
has to do with codes with locality and
in regenerating codes the there is a new
construction for an MSR code which is
high rate and I guess more importantly
because there have been other
constructions it has something that it
has low alphabets eyes and I will say
more about it later the other one is
relates to codes with locality this is I
mean I guess generalizations are always
welcome in practice so this is another
generalization which I think could be
useful in practice and these are the
famous papers that introduced these two
fields okay so high rate MSR codes so I
will just give a quick background on
switch on my local time here
regenerating codes are defined in the
following way so if you have a data file
then data pertaining to that file is
distributed across n nodes in the
network one big difference is that it
turns out that to make things work you
have to store multiple symbols per node
which another way of saying it is that
your code is not over a scalar alphabet
it's actually over a vector alphabet and
one of the requirements is that a data
collector who wants to recover the
entire file should be able to connect to
any K of these n nodes and recover the
entire file the other property is that
which which is the focus of a lot of
attention these days is that what if one
of these nodes fails then what you
should be able to do is you should be
able to connect to a subset of denotes
often d is n minus 1 as it is in my talk
and download beta symbols there are
alpha in each node but you download a
smaller number B
and repair this mode and the hope is
that d x beta will be significantly
smaller than the size of the file so
you're able to repair without by
downloading amount of data that's
comparable to how much you're going to
store in as opposed to what you do with
reed-solomon codes which there is no
really very efficient way of doing it we
will assume throughout this talk that
node repair is exact that means that
when a node fails we are going to
replace it with an exact replica I shunt
this figure because I think the focus is
not on the details but just to say that
there is a bound which comes from
network coding which tells you how large
your file can be and there are this can
be interpreted this is a cut-set bound
so it can be interpreted in different
ways so one way of saying that is that
if you fix KD and your file size there
are different parameters alpha and beta
for which you can actually meet this
inequality with equality so if you if
you have a set of parameters for which
equality holds then you have an optimal
code and we will interpret it in the
following way that you have if for a
given K D&B you have choices of alpha
and beta for which you can make this
bound hold with equality so in some
sense there are different flavors of
optimality okay and that is also called
the storage bandwidth repair trade-off
and so it looks something like this and
what you are trading off is repair
bandwidth d times beta or the total
amount of data download for repair
versus the amount of data that you store
per node alpha so here is alpha and that
is d beta and the extreme points are MSR
in MBR MSR which is the focus of this
talk is the point where you store the
least it's very efficient in terms of
storage but in terms of bandwidth this
other point is better but our focus is
this particular point
in terms of constructions for ms our
codes they have been many and you know a
lot of the authors are here there was
one when rush me any hardware at IC they
had come up with this product matrix
construction and then there was another
paper by chang-ho and kernan which built
on earlier results in this paper and but
both of these constructions were for
rate less than or equal to one-half and
so there was interest in saying well how
do you construct codes for rate greater
than one-half and they were
constructions so there was one paper
which established existence there was
another paper that constructed it for
the case of two parodies then Tom o Jing
and Josh Brook actually constructed it
partially in the sense that the only
repaired systematic nodes and then they
followed up in a subsequent paper in
which they actually rebuilt even the
parity nodes so this is an example of a
high rate MSR code so this does the job
in terms of rate but it has a slightly
large symbol alphabet so we so we'll
talk about that so the focus of this
talk is how do you actually get the
alphabet size down once they see the day
seem of sizzurp yeah I put these two
together yes I did not order it
chronologically I just mean you sir but
yeah the thing is that of course these
are publications and transactions and
you have no control over when they
actually appear and for example this
paper has not even been submitted I know
to the
so sub packetization level or alphabet
size so what is the story there so this
is all about this one this is all about
this one parameter alpha so you have the
number of symbols per node and the thing
is that you'd like to keep that to a low
value for practical reasons and the
question is how small can you make it
again I'm not talking to know logically
but there is a bound which is this which
says that if you take log of alpha to
base to log of alpha to base Delta what
is Delta Delta is 1 minus 1 upon r where
r is the redundancy n minus K for the
MSR case N and K kind of have the same
connotation that they have an ordinary
block codes that k is the rate k by n is
the rate so it's 1 minus 1 upon r and
this has this inequality has to be
satisfied now if your delta is you know
three for some integer like that then
you tend to think that well alpha has to
be on the order of 2 to the K so it has
to be exponential but the point is that
well what if it's not what if your
redundancy you know you're talking about
rates in practice which is you know
we've talked about rate half what if
you're interested in two-thirds
three-fourths four fifths five six seven
eight then this this number is going to
get very close to one and this is no
longer small so you can't make that
claim anymore and that's part of the
point of this talk so people were
looking in a different direction because
they fix our whereas we are not doing
that we're letting our grow within but
keeping the ratio the redundancy as a
fraction r by n small so the
construction to this construction here
which gave us a high rate MSR codes a
beautiful beautiful construction give
you alpha equal to R to the k plus 1 so
in that sense it's exponential present
construction gives you alpha equal to R
to the N by our so if n by r if r grows
with n then that could still that is
still polynomial so that's the thing
about this construction
so what a number which is less than 1 r
minus 1 by r oh maybe it's hard by r
minus 1 i'm a call it even don't like we
have a rare i think it's our by arming
son sorry yeah we can talk offline but i
believe that is true yes adult is very
close to one but greater than one yeah
fine the units of our face [ __ ] here no
it's just symbols over some finite field
FQ so that's another issue yeah so there
is also an issue of what is that q and
in that construction q will come up but
for so far these i'm in general for the
problem if i choose a larger feel sighs
then I can always observe brick I can
always have a small and I'm sorry not
clear I don't think it's quite clear oh
sorry assuming linear codes yes yes yes
well this packetization etc I think for
non linear codes is completely different
volume so linear code sorry I should I
mention it so in the present
construction what we have is alpha is R
to the N by our and there's a parameter
in this construction t so variable to
provide constructions of the form with
the rate is t minus 1 upon T so it's
two-thirds three-fourths and the thing
is that the sub packetization is r cubed
R for our fifth and so that's just a
quick overview what we will do so the
construction does build a lot on this
earlier work so we'd actually draw a lot
of the ideas from this earlier work so
we will how will we explain construction
so it's a parity check point of view
will first present a simplistic view of
the parities that we use that will
enable you to repair but Willie not
enable you to handle data collection
then we will refine this then we'll
define this further and to a point where
data collection is also possible so it's
interesting it turns out that in these
cases by just appealing to a large field
size you can take care of the data
collection it's the repair where you
need some topology which enables you to
handle repair so that is what it seems
to me this is all this is a recent
results so it's only about few weeks of
time thinking about this so the
parameters of the particular
construction are that n will be T times
Q secures the similar alphabet and then
k is t minus 1 upon q TR times q d is n
minus 1 so you talked to all the other
nodes for repair alpha is Q to the T
beta is Q to the t minus 1 and R which
is n minus K is just Q and your rate is
t minus 1 upon T and alpha you can also
write Q to the T as R to the N by our
okay so that's those are the parameters
now the notation that we actually use in
the construction is that well we are
going to think of each code word is an
array which is these are the nodes the n
nodes of the network in each of them is
going to store alpha symbols so this
sorry it's an alpha by n knot in Val for
alpha by n code word array so this is
the first symbol in the node second
symbol loss alpha the symbol and so on
and I'm going to show a bunch of
equations but only to give the flavor so
the code in the array will index it in
the following way l and theta will
identify the node and x will identify
the particular symbol within the node l
you can think of as identifying a class
or a group of nodes and theta is a
particular node within that class and so
LF you talk about the LF not group the
theta node in the exit symbol and L
varies between 1 and T theta varies over
fq and X varies over F Q to the tedious
now the parity-check so the parity-check
so i told you that i will give you a
simplistic view point which does not
work but which will enable you to handle
the pair but not data collection then
we'll refine it so in a simple you can
think of the parity checks is just being
draw some parity checks that is when you
think about the all the data being
stored as an array then you some the
rows for parity checks and then you do
what I think in the earlier paper was
called zigzag parity checks but I I just
seem to feel that you should call it
jump parity checks because there's a
particular jump that takes place which
seems to enable you to do repair okay so
the equations are not important but
there is a jump in a little straighter
with an example so here's an example so
now you have six nodes so q is to hear
you have six nodes and we are shooting
for rate two thirds so you have six
nodes here and each node actually stores
eight symbols now I am only showing some
of the row para draw some parity checks
so you can see that is represents a row
some parity check meaning that these
symbols are covered by that so some
linear combination of these six symbols
will equate to 0 to begin with we can
just assume that all these the constants
are one but actually you will need to
put in some constants and that constant
we'll talk about later similarly there
is a dro somewhere parity check here and
so on there are others but these are all
that are relevant for repair so let us
assume that node 1 has gone down and you
want to actually fix it so you can see
that by taking use of these rows and
parities you can recover a b c and d
okay because the sum 0 so you know all
the others and these this is what you
download from all the other nodes you
download these four symbols from all
these other nodes okay so beta is Q to
the t minus 1 which should be four in
this case so you download these symbols
and so you can fix that okay so that
simple rose and parity enables you to
take that so the question is well how do
you actually take care of these and you
want to only draw upon these symbols so
this is where this jump parity is come
in so those equations are formulated in
such a way that the parrot the parity
jumps from this set to this set for this
particular node here it does some
strange thing
it also jumps in a similar way but you
have to reorder it reorient yourself but
it doesn't matter you still stay within
these rows so the jump parity actually
allows you to recover these by drawing
only upon those okay so in this way you
record all of this so this is the point
and something like this was also there I
mean this idea of zigzag parity was
there in the earlier paper but I think
one difference may be that the focus
there was on a fixed number of parities
perhaps and focus was on starting with
the systematic code whereas we just say
then there is nothing no systematic
notes all nodes are the same so those
are some too slight differences okay so
what are the refinements the refinements
our first of all you do bring in
coefficients so it's not roseanne
parities just doesn't mean you add the
symbols but you scale in it and then the
second thing is that you also need to
add some more terms to your jump parity
to help you do data collection so I that
is better illustrated like this so if
you took the raw parity checks that is
if you didn't do any refinement if you
just took this then your parity check
matrix will look something like this and
you can see that these are the rows and
parity which have a very regular
structure but this is the jump parity
which has where you see this this thing
has jumped here so the jump looks
different when you look at it from the
parity check point of view so the parity
check matrix is this section over here
so it looks different from this
viewpoint down from the other viewpoint
way we were looking at the code word
array ok so now on the other hand it
turns out that in order to enable data
collection what you do is you add some
extra terms which will make your parity
check matrix look like H is 80 plus h1
it is this Plus this and now it's not
hard to see using again tricks that have
been used in the literature before you
can actually select so I've written I
for which seems to suggest that I put
ones over here but actually not you're
going to put some variables in there and
there is an assignment of variables for
which you can show and I
the bound is n choose K the alphabet
size has to be at least n choose K you
can show that you can actually recover
the data by connecting to any K nodes ok
so yeah it is going a little bit fast
but the idea is just to give you the
flavor so that's all that I wanted to
say on this I'll just pause for a minute
if any questions ok so then the second
one is codes with hierarchical locality
and I talked about this in the lightning
talk so I was giving this talk in I was
giving an overview talk on region codes
for distributed storage in the
University of Melbourne and there was
one question from in the talk that said
that look if you have something like
this you have all these locality and
supposing you want to store a very large
file and you want but you want small
locality then your notion of locality is
not really scaling because you know if
you have more errors then this local
code can correct then you have to appeal
all the way to this big code which means
that you need to address some 14 symbols
so it's like a big jump from talking two
three four local repair to 14 for when
the local code cannot work so can you do
isn't there some way of doing something
in between and I guess it should have
been obvious that I mean not sure why
people didn't I mean people have talked
about hierarchical codes but not in this
particular context so so the idea was
that can you actually put a code in the
middle so to speak so that you have
these local codes and then you have this
global code and so what happens is that
if one of these small local codes fail
then you apply your appeal to what we
call the middle code ok these middle
codes can help you out and if they don't
fail then you go there and it turns out
all the theory carries over and in fact
this is quite it's not very difficult
it's you just I mean takes a little bit
of effort but not too much so you just
follow along the footsteps of the first
paper the paper with go Palin and it
follows
and what you get is so this now this
part over here is the bound on codes for
locality which you can interpret as the
singleton bound ok this is the singleton
bound the minimum distance but then
there is a little bit of a loss because
you're demanding locality and here this
is the bound for a code with locality
and because you are demanding this
middle locality you lose some more and
this carries on and the proof is proof
is very similar you try to actually
construct k minus 1 dimensional
punctured sub-code having a large
support than the minimum distance can be
determined from knowing how large that
support is so the program requires a
little bit of refinement but a similar
argument actually holds and so in terms
of constructions also it's interesting
that so there are I mean two very
general constructions one is the pyramid
construction for codes with locality
that back in two thousand seven
changhong and all had before the notion
of locality came and then there is now
the recent Tama and bark beautiful
construction which uses I mean that many
different ways of looking at it you can
think of it as using sub codes of a
reed-solomon code so it turns out that
both of those can also be generalized
there are some restrictions so so I'm
just going to show you how the alt
symbol locality that taman berg had can
actually be applied in this case so i
think a key element of their
construction is to actually think of the
symbols and order them according to a
cyclic groups so here's a cyclic group
so let's say that you're working the
field of 25 element so it has a cyclic
group of size 24 so here's the cyclic
group these are this is it subgroup this
is a further subgroup this is a cassette
and these are other causes so you take a
look at it like this and now what this
decomposition means is that the elements
of this identify the support of the
local codes so the local codes have as
their support these
alright so far so good now how about the
code so the code okay here's another way
of looking at the time about
construction now you you want to
construct a code which is four three two
that means it has blocked length for you
want dimension 3 and you want minimum
distance too so if you restrict your
code so that it looks like a polynomial
right of degree 2 right then by
addressing these coefficients you can
get dimension 3 and since it cannot
cannot have more than two zeros you have
minimum distance too so these so if you
construct your code in such a way that
when the code polynomial is restricted
to this support of length 4 it looks
like this then you have a local code and
you want the same local code in all of
your six local codes so now you can
actually view this as a Chinese
remainder question saying okay you know
what the polynomial looks like modulo
the Annihilator polynomial of that
particular set and because it's cyclic
it's very sparse it's X to the 4 minus 1
and that turns out to be important so
modulo this Annihilator polynomial it
looks like this so you can lift it and
these are all relatively prime so you
can lift it here and then again you can
lift it now but if you do it in this way
then you will only get a local code this
thing will only have locality and no
global minimum distance so for global
minimum distance what you have to do is
you have to actually pre-code these data
and that's very general without loss of
generality in such a way that you
increase the minimum distance which
means you knock out the higher degree
coefficients and it turns out that
organizing things according to groups
makes this sparse and so you don't pay
too much of a penalty to knock out
higher degree terms and therefore get
for example if you knock down 22 21 20
okay then at 18 so you are minimum
distance 6 because the polynomial can
only have 18 zeros okay so that is how
the
is done and in fact that's what happened
here so you had so if you just lift it
so this is just the raw lifting of the
local codes of the polynomial which
gives you a locality but nothing else
and then what you actually do is you put
you so there are 3 6 9 12 15 18 right so
there are 18 symbol so what you do is
you I think you just need some equations
to knock these down and so I think you
need for because you also need to take
care of what happens here so by giving
up four so you pre-code these the data
that goes into these local codes and use
that to kill some of these higher degree
terms and as I said the sparsity helps
here and that gives you this and that
gives you the code that has minimum
distance six okay so that's how you can
actually get this and so yeah so there's
also the there is a pyramid construction
of by your chin Hong and others back in
2007 that that gives you information
symbol locality and it's based on
actually taking the generator matrix and
splitting the columns in a certain way
but that also carries over but i do not
think i'll go too much into the details
just I guess one last thing I wanted to
say earlier but I forgot in the interest
of disclosure so so they actually the
construction the this high rate MSR
construction came from Baron jet and I
think my contribution was that I was
when we were discussing the zigzag paper
I was telling him this is the way you
should actually look at the indexing of
the parity checks and that helped him
and the other thing was that I always
had this feeling that you know the
focusing on the fixed number of parity
checks doesn't seem right because for
example we know that you can construct
rate half codes with alphabet size no
longer the block length so it would seem
more natural that ok for half you need a
small field size for two-thirds you need
more and so on so that also and that
turned out to be true in this
construction can you improve it even
further it I think it may be possible
because if you if you specialize this to
the case of rate one-half you get a
slightly larger level of sub
packetization then you absolutely need
so maybe there's some script for
improving it I think with that I'll
actually stop here so for this MSR
construction so i use the few sighs so
what is it n choose K n choose K fine
with you but that's so that goes back to
what I think nihar results asking so I
don't know our our focus was on Suffolk
so they are like to lay code yeah so not
I mean you don't I mean a cyclic group
always has subgroups right so there's no
so for example here so for example if
you take the field of 25 elements it has
a cyclic subgroup of order 24 24 so in
that you have a subgroup of size 12 and
it's caused it multiplicative / suburbs
and this cyclic subgroup in turn has a
cyclic subgroup of size 4 and it's
cosets so it comes very naturally I'm
just saying that that is the natural
extension of your construction to this
and the point is that you are just
lifting because you know what you want
your code word to look like locally so
the question is what does it look like
globally but that's just the Chinese
remainder theorem and I think you
mention it do you mention something like
that in your paper also yeah you showed
those polynomials of this various levels
side so you are hiding coefficients
they're not all the same polynomial yes
yes yeah absolutely that's right we
should have put a comma instead of
opening a plus right just the monomial
terms have been identified but not the
polymer
any more questions and that's big DJ
again